heute möchte ich meine freude ausdruck
verleihen dass immer mehr bundesländer
in deutschland die strenge zweijährige
im 1 jannik bone impfausweis ist wieder
möglich endlich es ist der erste schritt
richtung freiheit und dass diese
spalterischen maßnahmen endlich enden
länder wie schweden haben die menschen
nie gespalten aber wir wir haben es
getan und als gesellschaft einfach
hingenommen wer gar die ausgrenzung
wurde ja noch von teilen der bevölkerung
als solidarischer akt gefeiert ich frage
mich seit monaten welcher politiker kann
diese schweizerischen maßnahmen noch
verantworten im blick auf die aktuelle
spezialisierungsgrad ist es besonders
bizarr die regierung darf uns nicht
länger zu maßnahmen zwingen und der
zweijährige rums ist ein guter erster
schritt
[Musik]
janina ich muss da gleich einsteigen da
ich sie wirklich wichtig finde dass du
dieses thema heute mitgebracht hast ich
habe hier noch sehr gut daran erinnern
genau einem jahr sind wir mit den jungen
unternehmern force
wirtschaftsministerium gezogen und haben
demonstriert für eine öffnung strategie
das ist ein jahr her und heute
diskutieren wir immer noch darum unter
dem handel hat wirklich die letzten zwei
jahre massiv unter diesen
einschränkungen gelitten und deswegen
muss jetzt auch die öffnung kommen wir
brauchen auch in anderen bereichen eine
öffnung strategie schauen wir uns die
kitas an die schulen wir brauchen einen
plan es kann nicht sein dass die
regierung erst praktisch reagiert wenn
der öffentliche druck zu groß wird
deswegen bin ich voll bei dir wir müssen
öffnen wir müssen diesen massiven
wirtschaftlichen schaden jetzt auch
auffangen verändern und es war ja nicht
nur anschauen also natürlich ist der
wirtschaftliche schaden groß aber der
schaden für die menschen die zwei gehen
nicht entsprechend konnten aus welchen
gründen auch immer war auch sehr groß
und es ging dabei ja von anfang an und
das ist eigentlich politisch so gar
nicht akzeptabel um schikane umerziehung
wenn ich also man wollte also wir haben
ja vorher als es noch gar keinen
impfstoff gab auch alle an masken und
tests geglaubt und gehofft dass die
wirken und was aussagen können und man
kann überhaupt nicht verstehen warum
masken und tests nicht sozusagen bei
gesunden menschen wog ein
krankheitsverdacht wohl nicht völlig
reichen sollen um auch ein schuhgeschäft
zu betreten ich finde ja man müsste
einfach eine grundsätzliche sichtung all
der maßnahmen die inzwischen aufgelaufen
sind vornehmen zweig ist ein punkt ist
es ja nicht einsehbar dass man im
gewerbegebiet wenn man zu kaufland geht
einfach rein geht mit seiner maske und
nebenan
center wo man zu zweit auf 300
quadratmetern steht da zeigt man vorher
sein seinen impfnachweis aber es ist
auch sonst einiges aufgelaufen also
seltsamen hotel regeln wo alle geimpft
sind dreifach gern auch das personal
mann mit der maske rein kommt und dann
trotzdem noch zwischen eine
plexiglasscheibe hat und beim frühstück
sich plastik an zu ansehen und die
minibar ist leer und die minimoys ist
natürlich leer salzstreuer gibt es nicht
damit man sie nicht anfassen kann und in
stadien sitzen dann 3000 leute obwohl
60.000 reinpassen alle auf einer seite
dicht beieinander da fragst du dich auch
was soll das also es ist schon sehr
kurios und da könnte man einfach mal
ordentlich ausmisten und das sinnlose
weglassen und dann ging es schon viel
besser aber er heißt da als politiker
sind ja politiker von der union die
union hat ja auch vieles mitgetragen
oder angela merkel umgesetzt auch immer
durchgesetzt ja bei am abend meine frage
an sie es wie kann denn ein politiker
die maßnahmen gerade ob noch
verantworten mit blick auf die aktuelle
aus italiens rate ich muss sagen ich
finde das sollte der politik doch gerade
wirklich jetzt langsam wirklich langsam
wird sie ein bisschen bizarr oder ich
glaube das ist der entscheidende punkt
was herr schuler gesagt hat dass die
maßnahmen am ende gut begründet sein
müssen und sinn machen müssen damit sie
auch akzeptiert werden sie dürfen
einfach begründet ja das ist es eben
also zum eintreffen sind nicht
widersprüchlich sein und zum anderen war
die begründung immer dass die
überlastung der intensivstation unter
krankenhäuser droht und wenn das nicht
mehr der fall ist wo von immer mehr
krankenhäuser ärzte berichten auch
henrik strikt hat das heute noch mal
gesagt dann kann man nicht jetzt auf wie
es der gesundheitsminister tut auf
andere begründung plötzlich abheben
sondern man muss sagen wir haben immer
gesagt diese einschränkung gibt es wegen
der überlastung der krankenhäuser wenn
das nicht mehr droht dann müssen wir
auch locker und da müssen wir eine klare
lockerungs perspektive aufzeichnen das
sagen auch immer mehr virologen und da
kann man nur sagen herr lauterbach
listen todes 1 wobei die union natürlich
das problem hat ganz heftig bei der
impfpflicht mit gerührt zu haben und
sich da voll mit auf den zug gesetzt zu
haben auch die einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht mit beschlossen zu haben und
jetzt macht sich so langsam wieder vom
acker völlig zu recht wie ich finde
trotzdem habe ich nie verstanden warum
die union so auf dem impfpflicht fahrt
gewesen ist das erbe der kanzlerin kann
es ja nicht allein gewesen sein was man
da verwalten wollte denn eines ist doch
klar wir haben im laufe der pandemie
immer wieder gesehen dass unsere
einsichten in das wirken des impfstoffs
aber auch in das verhalten des virus
sich zum teil von woche zu woche
geändert haben und jetzt eine pflicht zu
beschließen für eine zeit jetzt soll es
im herbst soll man die auf vorrat
beschließen von der wir nicht wissen
welches virus dann kassiert ob der
impfstoff noch wirkt finde ich einfach
völlig sinnlos wobei das impfen ja
gerade der weg raus ist aus den
maßnahmen die sie ja auch gerade beklagt
haben und das ist ja auch was wir ganz
stark aus der wirtschaft ja aber wer
einmal hinter sich kleidet besuchen denn
zum beispiel wenn ich jetzt feststellen
der impfstoff schützt mich nicht ich
kann mich infizieren es schützt aber
auch nicht davor dass sich das virus
weiter gebe dass der effekt der mobile
patient soll geschützt werden der wirt
der tritt gar nicht ein sie seien ja mal
so ich muss eben ich müsste dann auch
noch wieder testen dann wäre aber der
test eigentlich das wichtiger und und
nicht zu sehr in geht ja nicht nur um
die vermeidung ganz kurz es geht ja
nicht nur um die vermeidung von
ansteckungen sondern eben darum den
effekt zu erreichen der sich jetzt
abzeichnet dass eben die krankenhäuser
nicht mehr so überlastet werden und das
kriege ich am ende nur hin mit der
impfung damit mit der impfung so und das
ist dann auch zur not da muss man eben
gucken wie wirkt der impfstoff wie ist
die entwicklung deswegen finde ich die
idee auf vorrat das zu magath und
konkreter belange krankenhäusern das
pflegesystem und das gesundheitssystem
in deutschland ziemlich marode ist das
gab es ja auch schon vor corona dass
ärzte zeitung auch gewarnt haben dass
die intensivstation voller auf das hat
corona er nicht erfunden oder nein
sicher nicht ich meine wir sind im
internationalen vergleich glaube ich gar
nicht so schlecht aufgestellt was
reserven bei intensivstation angeht aber
ich denke haben alle gelernt in der er
an dem ihr jetzt sondern für so eine
extremsituation hat es offensichtlich
dass die intensivbetten quote der welt
und ehrlicherweise muss man auch sagen
die ganze idee mische lage von
nationaler tragweite die sollte ja genau
diesen zweck dienen die überlastung zu
verhindern ist war der höchste wert von
koma patienten auf intensivstationen um
die 25 prozent er war also zu jedem
zeitpunkt selbst als es ganz schlimm war
in der zweiten welle insofern war dieses
argument von anfang an heikel
unter verfassungsrechtlichen
gesichtspunkten und jetzt wird es jetzt
wird es wirklich absurd aber ich aber an
diesem punkt fehlt mir tatsächlich auch
noch die strategie wenn ich mit pflege
unternehmen spreche das thema
pflegekräfte und bei den einrichtungen
märz die impfpflicht kommen soll wir
haben jetzt schon das thema zu wenig
pflegekräfte was passiert also ich habe
mit einem pflegeunternehmen erst vor
kurzem gesprochen der mir sagt 40
prozent meines pflegepersonals ist nicht
geimpft was mache ich jetzt wenn diese
impfpflicht kommt dann fehlen uns noch
mehr pflegekräfte weg da brauchst auch
eine strategie der regierung wie das
ganze funktionieren soll das noch die
praktisch betreuung von den älteren von
dem legen denn gewährleistet ist es ein
großes thema ja es gibt eine mindest
fachkraftquote in pflegeheimen das
müssen approbierte pfleger seien und
wenn mir von denen eine bestimmte
deshalb von der stange gehen dann kann
ich die ganze einrichtung nicht machen
das ist einfach das problem und das ist
eigentlich auch der punkt den söder
sieht wenn er sehenden auges in einen
pflegenotstand reihen marschiert dann
selbst dann lieber die imperia das kann
ich ganz gut verstehen auch wenn allen
kehlen haben wir den mops beschlossen
zehn mann auch durch das kann ja nicht
das motto sein also da bin ich auch
total mal also ich bin ja nicht der
größte markus söder fan ich hatte ihnen
ja für den populisten aber und für so
ein pseudo popstar ist nicht mein
lieblings politiker aber ich muss sagen
ich finde das gut und ich werde jeden
politiker an diesem tisch feiern jetzt
sagt okay wir machen sie es doch anders
wir machen die amtlich nicht weil das
dürfen wir können nicht sagen nein heißt
weiterhin im harten kurs fest oder die
keine umfaller seit ist doch super wenn
sie sich jetzt ein bisschen dahingehend
ändern dass mit der impfpflicht wie
wahrscheinlich ist es denn eigentlich
noch er heißt ja dass sie kommt wie
sehen sie das eigentlich persönlich sind
sie für die pflicht also meine
persönliche meinung ist dass es
wahrscheinlich wenn es so bleibt wie
jetzt er nicht kommt wenn man sich
anguckt wie die verläufe sind bei omi
kronen wenn man sich anschaut das sagt
ja auch henrik strikt wie der impfstoff
wirkt eben dass er nicht verhindert dass
man sich auch weiter ansteigt das sind
glaube ich alles faktoren die man eben
berücksichtigen muss nur wir wissen es
eben heute noch nicht wie das im herbst
aussieht vielleicht kommt eine neue
variante vielleicht kommt neuer
impfstoff vielleicht entwickeln sich die
dinge anders als wir denken das haben
wir in der pandemie mehrfach erlebt und
bevor wir in den nächsten lockdown
müssen und die wirtschaft ja auch
riesige schäden nimmt das bedroht auch
lebensgrundlagen und so weiter und so
fort hat sich jetzt müssen wir das erst
in stans ja eigentlich nicht so viel
gebracht haben als es gab jetzt auch der
studie wieder aus erika die gezeigt hat
die lok dort haben ja gar nicht so viel
gebracht im kampf gegen das
infektionsgeschehen na ja ich glaube
schon dass man auch in anderen ländern
sieht das ist zum teil deutlich größere
belastung der intensivstation gab darum
ging es ja und ich finde schon also wenn
ich jetzt ein autounfall habt dann will
ich nicht irgendwie verrecken müssen nur
weil irgendwer seine maske nicht tragen
wollte und die intensivstation blockiert
so die frage ist gibt es diesen
zusammenhang und wenn wir jetzt sehen
dass die intensivstationen eben nicht
überfüllt sind dann muss man auch die
maßnahmen hinterfragen und kann nicht
jetzt auf andere faktoren plötzlich
abstellen und seinem anwalt die
unionsfraktion wird ja morgen einen
corona impfpflicht vorsorge
gesetzentwurf beraten in interner
sitzung nächsten nächste woche zur
disposition stellen da will man
allerdings nur die rechtlichen
rahmenbedingungen für eine mögliche
impfpflicht besprechen so dass man
gewappnet ist für die
ausführungsbestimmungen usw alles
weitere muss dann natürlich vor ort
geregelt werden du weißt ja gar nicht ob
sie jetzt eine pflicht beschließen für
die dritte vierte impfung oder für ein
ganz neuen impfstoff oder wofür
überhaupt eigentlich also mal sehen was
da rauskommt das ist so ein bisschen
inzwischen weg aber ich glaube die union
trete gut daran die regierung auch
kritisch bei der impfpflicht zu
begleiten das tun wir ja auch ich meine
dass er genau der punkt eben den
instrumentenkasten zu erweitern deswegen
war auch die abschaffung dieser
pandemischen lage von von nationaler
tragweite nicht richtig weil man eben
instrumentenkasten eingeschränkt hat und
jetzt geht es wieder
naja die möglichst das schafft ja nur
die möglichkeiten für die bundesländer
eben instrumentenkasten zu haben um
möglichst effektiv arbeiten zu können um
eben locker usw
aber die regierung muss da jetzt mein
vorschlag machen wie man das praktisch
umsetzt das ist doch jetzt leider nicht
mehr unsere aufgabe das in jedem detail
vorzuschlagen sondern da muss die
regierung endlich mal aufwachen aus
ihrem dornröschenschlaf und meine
anderen die bürger geschützt werden
müssen von der politik auch mit dem
regierungsrat ich habe heute ganz klar
viele piaggio auf mein kollege ist in
schweden gewesen der eine scheiße
gemacht die fand ich sehr spannend da
der nämlich gesagt die menschen haben
ihm dort vor ort gesagt sie haben
maßnahmen vorgeschlagen bekommen wurden
aber nicht dazu gezwungen und erst wenn
ich einen ganz schönen gedanken besteht
es überhaupt der regierung noch länger
zu uns eigentlich zu zwingen sachen
umzusetzen sollte sie nicht lieber jetzt
vorschläge machen weil das jetzt gerade
dient die stationen vorlaufen blick auf
die aktuelle ausführung gerade jetzt
können wir jetzt richtig aber das ist ja
genau was ich sagen das ist tatsächlich
aufgabe der regierung das dann auch zu
tun und diese grundlagen zu erarbeiten
die man dafür braucht es geht darum
werkzeuge zur verfügung zu haben wenn es
zum beispiel wieder eine neue variante
gäbe oder die impfstoffe sich nicht mehr
als wirksam herausstellen das kann ja
passieren ich hoffe es alles nicht ich
glaube auch nicht dass es wahnsinnig
wahrscheinlich ist aber für den fall
geht es darum instrumente zu schaffen
das ist die position der union aber die
regierung muss er konkret sagen was wie
man es auch praktisch dann unsere tassen
interessant da hat corona nicht als
erstes aber auch corona wieder ganz
unterschiedliche mentalitäten in den
einzelnen ländern freigelegt weil im
juni in großbritannien da haben die
gerade ihre ihren freedom day
verschieben müssen weil die zahlen
wieder nach oben ging aber da haben sie
natürlich nicht die papst zu gemacht und
man sonst weiter draußen und man ging
auch weiter shoppen ja das leben
verändern war deswegen ja nicht wir
müssen jetzt da irgendwie sowas
verschieben die schweden haben auch da
eine anderen zusammenhalt die dänen auch
die deutschen sind grundsätzlich so
strukturiert wenn ein problem erkannt
ist muss es gelöst werden so luther und
wenn wir feststellen dass die dass die
verschuldung ein übel ist dann wird
jetzt angefangen zu sparen da sagt der
grieche natürlich ja gut deshalb habe er
grundsätzlich recht aber noch nicht
jetzt passt gerade nicht nächste woche
da sind ganz unterschiedliche
mentalitäten und deshalb administrieren
wir auch so liebevoll durch bis ins
eigene wohnzimmer drei leute aus 15
haushalten unter 14 mit fußmatte oder
ohne das ist eine ganz komische
geschichte die wir glaube ich aus den
genen nicht so schnell rauskriegen